do you see somebody has created a devlin
mcgregor website
no did you see that i have seen it no
yes
dr lentz is on it is on it as security
yes yes yes yes and yes
all the yes i've seen it it exists i
don't know who spends the time doing
that
but all i say to that person is well
done well done
i do not say get a life i say well done
no appreciate we want more well we need
to know
if only richard campbell and uh yeah and
uh
you know well i guess uh gerard was able
to have that too right
yeah eight four four two oh four rich
number doll for our radio audience has
just rejoined us we just had a very
important conversation about the
fugitive
oh my god i mean everything's up the
alley of our of our next guest who is
kind enough to call
in every single wednesday during the
football season it's been about a good
month so we miss him
uh he had us at hello on good morning
football and his podcast 10 questions
with kyle brandt on spotify and the
ringer
is dynamite his guest this week chris
are you ready for this
pat mcafee yeah good buddy uh another
national treasure pat mcafee he is kyle
brown how are you kyle
he falsified his research he falsified
his research so devlin mcgregor could
bring you
the pro oh what a great plan god i love
fugitive talk with you rich
oh it is the best it is the absolute
best there was a
one uh we we took a a week of down time
after the super bowl
uh there was a meme uh on twitter about
you know drop a movie line
uh the random movie line that's familiar
only two
yeah yeah only to to uh the fans of the
movie and the one i chose from the
fugitive was uh you were pointing my gun
at me
you know and that's just that's the
random line i think only rich i saw that
tweet
and i sat there for a second and i said
hold on i'm putting your gun in you i
oh that's deputy samuel gerard and
that's on the phone
with kimball and kills do you remember
what i said i remember you pointing your
gun at me you said i'm not trying to put
together a puzzle
well i am trying to put together a
puzzle and i just found a big piece and
he puts my phone down
and lets them trace him to the one-armed
man's house oh god i could do this all
day
right to the one-armed man house um it's
great to be on with you rich
you and i have come such a long way in
in our in our on-air relationship and
yet to use uh
one of your new favorite phrases i feel
like we're just getting started hey now
everybody
fascinating clip where he casually
reveals and clearly didn't know this was
coming no one could
that he's never been completely
satisfied with one of his performances
that's right
he's never completely satisfied and i
was immediately riveted
absolutely i couldn't believe that
either that he said he's never
he's never been thoroughly satisfied and
then you know you've interviewed him for
your pod too so you know
that the way he tells stories um you
don't want to interrupt his flow
but i immediately i almost interrupted
him on it on the spot to say
so the one that you won the oscar for
for dallas buyers club that wasn't
it uh i mean you've got to be kidding me
and uh
i i i never asked about wolfe of wall
street and and he went in the direction
of
of of that that i i will direct people
to the pod because um
i don't know the line that he said that
left off this the page at him is
something that is safe for this
particular work but
um uh he he's dynamite man there's no
doubt about it so good and rich you you
use the word flow
very generously because mcconnell has
that that texas flow
where he will stop for a very
pregnant 40 weeks pregnant pause to
collect his thoughts and then
then continue and you know you just
trust it because
he's so original and it's going to go a
good place and
i i'm telling you i just i just got
immediately riveted just awesome stuff
well i appreciate you bringing that up
because it is a new labor of love for me
um and kyle brown here on the rich eisen
show
so um you know i came on the air talking
about cap numbers
and try to put it in perspective about
you know
uh the fact that what the quarterback
eats up of the cap and dak now actually
eats up four percent
less for the cowboys now that this
signing has taken place
that you'd rather be in the position of
having
kyler lamar alan baker herbert tua
uh and i'll leave darnold out of it for
the second for for the moment
then maybe to be in the boat with matt
ryan at 22
of the cap that he's eating up or kirk
cousin 16 and a half
eating up and you know the one team i
always
or even maybe russ at 17 he's just one
of the only few guys it just seems that
that that that once your quarterback
gets north of 15
of your cap you're in danger of not
winning it because you can't surround
them and russ is like i need protection
and the question is is like can they
afford it
so on and so forth i wonder what your
philosophy is certainly with your team
that you grew up loving
yeah now on the quarterback market um
and maybe needing to start from scratch
if they
if the ownership is is comfortable with
the people they
they they might give only one more year
or two you have the floor
yeah it's it's conflicting i think for
fans i think the day that you draft a
quarterback and they take the picture
and hold up the jersey
is really exciting like that's you're
gonna buy that jersey you love it we got
a new hope a new quarterback
that's a great day but the day that the
quarterback signs the huge contract and
i mean this
modern era huge it's it's it's
bittersweet it's conflicting because
you're like okay we got our guy
they invested and they're in but are we
gonna win this thing
because to your point rich point to the
quarterback
recently who's make huge money all these
guys your name
who won the super bowl it's they're not
there it's
rookie contract patrick mahomes it's
continuously
discount brady it's it's those guys not
only they're not winning the super bowl
i'm talking about
russ and rogers and all the you know the
big money guys
they're not sometimes not even getting
there so we are on a streak right now of
when's the first time that some a
quarterback making 37 million making 40
million is going to win the super bowl i
i i don't think it's a coincidence
and i think as a player as a shoot as a
bears enthusiast like me
this they got a whole different set of
problems the bears fans would love to
overpay for a quarterback
that is the biggest champagne problem of
all time i've reached the point with
this bears thing rich
where i'm saying screw it let's try
something irresponsible
because it's been 102 years of wanting a
quarterback
trade everything everything that is not
nailed down
and i mean mac roquan eddie jackson
cody whitehead their best lineman as i
heard you say on the air uh
i think it's the deed to soldier field
just anything for desean
or russ either of them and there will be
a ticker tape parade
past the field museum downtown chicago
just for getting a quarterback as a
bears fan just
just once in my life i would love to say
man we got a great quarterback if only
we could build a team around them i just
want to lose 53 to 51 i would rather do
that than do what they're doing all
these years
what about alex smith and i say that
knowing that you interviewed him just a
couple of weeks ago
yeah um and and the convert because he's
not i don't think he's done i don't
think he wants to you know he
went through all those surgeries just to
come back to mentor trevor lawrence
you know and and so he's a guy that
clearly was around when naggy was there
and he was the guy who was
taking them to the playoffs before
mahomes took it over
what about that concept what did you
sense from alex when you interviewed him
on your podcast a few
weeks ago it's it's a great name to
bring up because i feel like
it's it's a snake in the grass in this
whole thing we're doing right now i'll
tell you why
alex smith had this to say his and i'm
paraphrasing but his thought was
look i didn't know how the leg was going
to hold up i had no idea i knew i wanted
to get back out there
i did not know what to expect and then i
banged on it and i banged on it and i
banged on it and i was
he himself was palpably shocked how well
it held up he said he felt fine he said
he felt like himself
and he wants to play a lot more football
there's this idea of
when i asked him about this i said all
right so you're the comeback player of
the year
that is incredible little bow on your
career
now you have this this beautiful wife
and these children you've made all the
money in the world alex you're totally
respected you know you walk away
you've done it you made the comeback
congratulations now you walk away
and you have once nothing to do with
that in it to the question of
why bother what's the risk because he
loves playing he's
he loves the game and he has more more
winning to do let's be honest he
he was by far the best quarterback on
washington last year
they if they had started him from week
one
that that's a 9 10 11 win team and i
really mean that they win the division
anyway
and now they jettison him so someone
like the bears
someone like the patriots it's one of
these other teams that may be
dissatisfied looking to move
like the dolphins like alex smith all he
does
is win i i think it's a great name
and the bears fans what happened let's
say the bears make move for alex smith
it doesn't go over well alex smith oh
game manager can he hold up
he wins i think if the bears got alex
smith this season they will win
right don't turn it over let the defense
only give up 17 you put 21-24 on the
board i mean that's how he went 5-1
for the washington football team as a
starter this year i mean it's pretty
much it yeah
it works and and you got good players
around them and you're keeping robinson
and you have montgomery like that would
work and
listen people say oh he missed the
playoff game as far as i understand the
playoff game injury had nothing to do
with the catastrophic injury it was just
bad timing and he was
out there and as we saw like you know
washington was close with tampa in that
game washington washington played
tampa better than kc did in the super
bowl i i i know alex smith is not
uh deshawn it is not russell wilson it's
not trevor lawrence but
alex smith would win sign him this year
go to the playoffs win 10 games you'll
do it
kyle brandt here on the rich eisen show
um
and so what what else is on your your
good morning football docket you know
when you're sitting here
uh week before new league year all of
that stuff what are you guys talking
about
that leaps out a lot of questions rich
that are like um
so you know we're kind of at the
precipice new league year all this
regency
who's the team you think's got something
coming who's the team that's going to
do the cannonball into the deep end and
say whoa
and the team that i can't get away from
is
i just can't possibly see new england
playing it safe
i just don't and i mean specifically a
quarterback
the way things are now that i say this
you had a year
where you lost tom brady okay it went
cataclysmically
you lost players to opt out you took a
shot they think i
took a real bold shot with cam newton it
didn't work out
there's no way that bill belichick
mcdaniel at al are going to say well
we'll just go with jared stidham or
you know maybe we make a move for i
don't know mariota
no i think they're going to do something
incredibly dynamic
whether it be through an existing
quarterback or wildly moving up for one
of these rookies but
i just don't think they're going to sit
around and be like well it was fun for
20 years while tom was here now he can
win super bowls
and we're just going to eke our way to
eight and eight and try to rebuild i
think there is a
massive massive move coming from new
england well i mean and and
in that um yesterday uh i was just
going totally tin foil hat crazy ass
conspiracy to the point where tj
jefferson my
social media grand maester immediately
posted with the gif of charlie day
pointing to the board you know with all
that stuff you know with the strings and
all the the periodicals and
articles on the board um so i i i would
if i call this it's one of those trick
shots in in in billiards if you will i
mean
where all the balls go into the into the
pockets uh desean
to the dolphins tua to the
texans sam darnold to the niners who
then
uh make jimmy g available for the
patriots and the jets draft
zach wilson oh it's so immaculate that's
that's the
paul newman color of money you got the
queue upright and every
it's so clean i love it and i feel like
everyone gets happy
which is why i i'm skeptical of it
because i i'm i'm thinking there's going
to be disarray
and i just mean that was that didn't
even touch the rim
that went right down the net it was it
clearly you've put a lot of thought into
it um
of course it could all stop and none of
it could work
or none of it you were working with
named sean watson the text and say
nope you're not going anywhere my friend
and
you know we debate that a lot too in the
morning about is he really going to
leave you know what what's going to
happen
is he going to ever play down another
team uh i'm kind of come around into
saying that i think this time of year
the teams get so worked up so uh what
how can i clean this up
so uh randy for quarterbacks if you will
that i think that someone is going to
make maybe a
nearly ludicrous offer to the texans and
it will be the classic offer you can't
refuse and they'll finally say fine
go we never want to see you again and
we're going to take all this king's
ransom i think it will happen eventually
and you know again going back to these
numbers that i had here
to start the show um about uh
quarterbacks eating up percentage of the
cap i looked it up deshawn watson only
eats up currently in 2021
eight percent of the texans cap that's
it another reason why they're like right
you know another reason why they'll
either extract you know more
herschel walker type stuff on steroids
to use the phrase
or or they'll say there's no way that
they're going to trade him i mean
year two and this he's only eight
percent of their cap and they could try
and build something for their new
coach i i just don't know we'll they'll
just put a pin in that uh
because i do want to give you the last
couple minutes here to talk about
uh your conversation with mcafee which
has to be what the uh what the kids
might say epic
right yeah the kids are always saying
that it's it's lit and those are facts
as the kids also say i would say you you
have pat mcafee on and you're
you know you're expecting someone who's
a professional wrestler and he literally
is a professional just the rookie of the
year in fact
and the expectations are high and yet he
comes in and meets all of them and he's
everything we want
energetic anecdotal you know i asked
them something that involves you in fact
i was asking him about the night at the
draft in nashville 2019 when he
announced the colts pick
i think that was like his breakout
single i think that blew him up
i think everyone in nashville was
talking about him you on the call
and daniel jeremiah are laughing and i
said so when you come out and you do
this incredible bit
and you roast the titans like what went
into it and he proceeds to tell the
story of being
backstage drinking beers with shane
leckler and he bought his clothes
it's some sort of store on the way over
and goodell comes and gives him the fist
pound and then he comes out and
just kind of wings it and has orangutan
jokes and i think he left that stage a
star and the way he tells it just
backs all of that up you remember that
you know and also kyle
um for for those who might not have been
there
um lower broadway was jam-filled
with human beings i mean it was it just
as far as the eye can see
there were people there who are all
fired up for a the draft and b
the titans and for him to come out there
and troll like that
that that's similar to drew pearson
stepping up to the podium
in philadelphia with all of the ben
franklin uh
parkway uh filled with human beings
there for the draft and the eagles
it's it's on par with that uh but
obviously a little bit more millennial
and he look i i have nothing but love
for pat
you know he's he's one of the best so
the two of you must had a great
conversation i was so good
all kinds of stuff the wrestling stuff
the football stuff i really pressed them
on
pat you quit the nfl to join bar stools
at bar stool
years ago are you kidding me you tell me
you don't regret that well it was a wild
decision
and he has a really lucid insightful
answer that really got to the core of
who he is and at the end of it i i i was
i bought it i bought every word look
everybody everybody thinks you know
patch is some wacky punter who goes top
rope
for for you know uh either literally or
figuratively right
uh but he's got some outstanding
business sense
on all of this he knows exactly what
he's doing he knows what content
is and how people consume it and he
doesn't just throw anything against the
wall
um and so and he's got respect of a
bunch of people i mean aaron rodgers
sitting there in front of his brick
background
uh every single week win or lose um for
him
just speaks volumes obviously so that
was the best
absolutely the best soap uh everybody
check out mcafee
but first obviously come on if you
haven't checked out just getting started
oh stop kyle you're here to promote
it and i'm into it still i got three
hours to promote my podcast you're here
to promote yours
on ringer and spotify and before i let
you go what's your random movie line
drop one for me we'll see if we can get
it
what do you got for me okay i know
you've probably got a million of them in
your head right now the line is
you're officially out of limes jack
you're officially out of lines
jack limes right yes
oh your first shot of limes jack oh
that's boogie nuts
that's boogie nights roll a girl you got
it you're out of foul
please i mean if you're gonna go roll a
girl on me i mean my gosh
well i mean i've got a twelve ten and a
seven and a half yeah yeah
that would be tough for them to casually
walk in yeah you got one
i don't even think you can watch that
when you're parent with your parents
when you're like 40. i don't want to
watch
my dad right now although every single
time that i screw up when i say
something that i'm an idiot all i think
of is that scene
you know uh with philip seymour hopping
behind the behind the wheel of the car
thanks for the call appreciate it let's
do this uh let's do this uh let's do the
april let's let's set up the draft let's
do all that good stuff okay wait man
love it thanks again kyle that's right
brad check him out on good morning
football every single morning
on nfl network and his podcast uh
on ringer and spotify pat mcafee is his
guest this week
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here